training other people can teach you a
lot and if there's one thing I've
learned from coaching others is that
training performance and fitness are
extremely personal two people can
respond to the same workout and diet
plan in entirely different ways this
comes down to preferences to limb
lengths to hormones but it goes even
deeper than that
even your very personality can impact
your performance
the way you're programmed
your temperament and disposition
Who You Are
foreign
obvious ways this can be the case for
example people are more extroverted tend
to have more muscle mass and better
Fitness this is because many activities
that improve Fitness are also likely to
involve socializing spending time with
others and being very active
but here's another way in which
extroverts and introverts differ in
reaction speed
on average extroverts have faster
reflexes than introverts people often
misunderstand the distinction between
introverts and extroverts introverts are
not necessarily shy nor are all
extroverts confident the difference lies
in how individuals Orient their
attention and where they feel most
recharged I for example am extremely
introverted according to the popular
Myers-Briggs personality test anyway I'm
an infp in fact for anyone who's
interested when I tell people this
though they often don't believe me
that's because I'm quite outgoing in a
group and I talk a lot I'm not shy
but I also am happiest when I'm at home
on my own with my very close family
Reading Writing playing computer games
even most of my chosen Fitness
activities are solitary weightlifting
calisthenics rock climbing running I
like martial arts best when I'm
performing at solo and it takes me a lot
of willpower to actually go out and
spend time with people
I enjoy it when I'm there and I
genuinely like people but it is an
effort for me unlike a friend of mine
who says he's so extroverted he gets
lonely in the shower
as an introvert I spend more time in my
own head and that could explain why
someone like me would respond a little
slower to external stimuli interestingly
though it also seems the case that
introverts actually make fewer errors
when reacting a little more processing
occurs prior to the response and this
also allows for fewer mistakes
so there isn't one clearly Superior type
of Personality here
and it's easy to see how this could also
influence things like verbal fluency and
social interactions
[Music]
another interesting delineation is the
warrior versus Warrior discussion so
this is a category of personality that's
actually dictated by genetics
specifically we're looking at the gene
that codes for comt catacol o methyl
transferase this is an enzyme that
breaks down the catecholamine
neurotransmitters such as norepinephrine
epinephrine and dopamine in other words
some people will have genetically higher
levels of adrenaline and dopamine
flowing around their system at any given
time While others will have lower levels
the worries being those with higher
levels and the Warriors being those with
lower levels
of course you can also be a hybrid with
the levels that fall somewhere in the
middle
during everyday activities higher levels
of dopamine can actually result in more
brain activity
and this can provide a slight cognitive
Edge in some scenarios but the problem
is that during times of high stress this
can actually become too much for the
warrior type it's at this point that the
warrior type tends to step in and
outperform the warrior
as you might expect this makes the
warrior type slightly more suited to
certain types of competition for example
most MMA fighters are Warrior types
if you want to find out which type you
are you can use a genetic test
there's lots of good ones out there but
I recommend self-decode which I've been
using for years and which provides a
really wide amount of information on a
number of different health and fitness
related topics I'll leave a link to that
below and if you use it I'll also get a
commission so thank you for that in
advance you just need to send a saliva
sample or you can download and reuse
your DNA data from a site like ancestry
but if you'd rather not spend the money
you can likely reflect on your own
personality and make an educated guess
are you in your own head a lot do you
have racing thoughts do you get easily
flustered when under stress I'm so that
way inclined that I tend to forget my
own name when making appointments
so yes I'm definitely the warrior type
or are you seldom worried and good at
performing under pressure in which case
you might be a warrior
the good news is that once again there
are Pros to both kinds of performance
and ways to maximize your natural
potential according to one study fighter
pilots with the warrior genotype tend to
perform better on practical test
scenarios predictably the Warriors would
be distracted by their own anxiety
but when given sufficient time to
acclimatize to the stressful situation
where he has actually began to perform
better and there are ways that Warrior
types can mitigate their higher levels
of stress too for example they can use
meditation or CBT to maintain a calm
state of mind after all the stress
response only occurs if the individual
interprets the situation as stressful
so for these reasons some writers
actually refer to the two types as the
warrior type and the strategist as this
suggests less negative connotations for
the latter
likewise the warrior type might be able
to overcome some of the more negative
traits associated with their less wired
mentality by using strategies to amp
themselves up or even by using caffeine
if you're looking for a way to manage
your own cognitive State using an app
like today's sponsor endl can be a
fantastic option endl is an app that
creates personalized science-backed
soundscapes designed to help you focus
Drift Off to Sleep increase productivity
and more depending on your goals this
app uses patented technology to adapt in
real time to a host of different inputs
including the weather and even your
heart rate if you have a compatible
device it works with your circadian
rhythms and has been shown to boost
productivity significantly compared with
strategies like listening to playlists
andal also features special soundscapes
from well-known artists such as James
Blake Grimes and Alan Watts among others
it's accompanied by cool visualizations
and has a stunning design all of which
certainly help to put me in a focused
state of mind I love working in coffee
shops and letting endl provide the vibes
the first 100 people to download endral
at the link down below will get a free
week of audio experiences
here's some more bad news for the
strategist types though they also
typically have higher sensitivity to
pain in particular the reduced enzyme
activity associated with the comt val158
Met snip has been linked with chronic
back pain in studies
although strategists are no more likely
to experience things like disc
herniation in the first place for
example they do recover more slowly and
experience more chronic pain going
forwards
and that about tracks
that to put a win back in the strategist
column higher levels of adrenaline
actually mean that blood reaches the
muscles more quickly when needed we're
more ready to go this also Rings true
for me as someone who's been known to
walk into the gym and head straight over
to perform a near max bench press there
are many other factors that also play a
role for example estrogen actually slows
down comt meaning that women will
naturally have higher Baseline dopamine
levels on average so to do men with
lower levels of testosterone
there are no doubt countless other
interactions between various other
hormones genes neurotransmitters and
lifestyle factors just not a clear-cut
correlation
and of course we've only discussed a
couple of different personality traits
here this is a growing field of study
and one with a lot of promise
Charles poliquin for example was a fan
of using the Braverman test to learn
about his athletes and to help guide his
coaching
this psychometric test attempts to
create a neurotransmitter profile based
on answers to a number of questions
there isn't a huge body of evidence
backing up its accuracy but it's
certainly an interesting attempt to take
into account more neurotransmitters such
as Garber and acetylcholine
acetylcholine being the primary
excitatory neurotransmitter that's also
responsible for muscle fiber recruitment
across the neuromuscular Junction thus
it might illuminate an interesting link
between temperament and physical
strength this is also why Alpha GPC Can
Be an Effective pre-workout for some
people
I've also spoken before about the roles
of DHEA in neuropeptide y and the ways
that they can buffer the effects of
cortisol on the prefrontal cortex high
levels of these chemicals are identified
in top athletes and Special Forces
Personnel these top performers also seem
to exhibit both heightened sympathetic
arousal during stress and heightened
parasympathetic expression during
recovery in other words they get amped
up to a high degree during the times
when they need to but they're also able
to recover very effectively in between
those bouts of high performance
even your preferred chronotype or body
clock might be an important
consideration as it can affect what time
you perform best are you a dolphin a
lion a wolf or a bear and what might
Your Role once have been among small
groups of humans as a result
the bottom line is that humans are far
too complex to say that type A will
perform like X and don't get me started
on the actual Taipei Theory which was
actually invented to counteract bad
press for cigarette companies
what we can say is that your personality
disposition and biochemistry each have a
huge role in defining who you are and
how you perform learning to better know
yourself can be a highly effective way
to get more from your training
I hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys let me know a bit about
yourselves in the comments down below
what's your Myers-Briggs type do you
relate more with the warrior types of
the strategists extroverts or introverts
and did you get your DNA tested did you
find out anything interesting about
yourself as a reminder you can find a
link to self decode down in the
description
and a huge thank you once again to Paul
and Louise for letting me use their gym
and turn off all the lights it's a
fantastic place to train with amazing
coaching so if you happen to be local
then I highly recommend getting in touch
um guys you can find this full script as
an article over on my blog and there
you'll also find links to all of the
studies that I referenced or that back
up my points in this video Whatever type
of person you are I'm really glad you're
here so thank you so much for watching
this one guys
and bye for now